Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new venom 2 spider-man
video there's a whole bunch of new stuff
to break down I know we got a lot of
questions about what's happening this
summer in terms of all the movies coming
back movie trailers when are we going to
get the venom 2 trailer Tom Holland has
also been very active lately because
he's getting ready to start filming
uncharted and then spider-man 3 so
there's a lot of spider-man stuff
happening for the rest of the year if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos will do
a new Amazon giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and let me
know what kind of spider-man cameo you
want to see in venom 2 so you're
starting with the big stuff first number
5 what's going on with the venom 2
trailer the proper trailer in what's
going on with that movie right now
because Comic Con 2020 is happening in
about two weeks as I'm posting this
video right now they just announced the
full schedule of panels that are going to
be happening there everyone just
pre-recorded their panels and they're
going to be streaming it online for free
but Andy Serkis recently who directed
venom 2 was doing some special charity
readings of The Hobbit and Lord of the
Rings with a whole bunch of Gollum voice
during that he revealed all the work
that he was doing on venom 2 from his
house because they actually finished
filming the movie before the big virus
shutdown fortunately so they are able to
work on the movie during the lockdown
first of all I've been very fortunate
I've been able to carry on editing this
little number which is coming your way
due next year and secondly I want to
invite you to come with me on an
adventure no joke he's just editing the
movie from his house this summer the
post-production is being done elsewhere
but originally Sony had this whole plan
for how the Morbius movie was going to
crossover with venom 2 in their shared
spider-man universe gets bigger with
more characters then they were going to
release spider-man 3 after that it was
going to get even bigger they're going to
start slowly getting to their spider-man
venom crossover and it was all going to
make sense they did have a plan for it
so because venom 2 was originally
supposed to come out in October they
actually had the venom 2 trailer ready
to go back in March and April because
that's when the first venom trailers
dropped for the very first movie they
have a very reliable marketing schedule
for all this kind of footage but because
of the virus they pushed venom 2 till
June next year in Morbius is coming out
in March spider-man 3 is coming out in
November 2021 so the whole big Easter
Egg sinister six
venom spider-man crossover a shared
universe plan is still intact
but it just means that all the marketing
all the trailers just get pushed down
the year there was a report I saw going
around the internet about Sony dropping
venom 2 footage this summer on their own
outside of comic-con because there is no
Sony Pictures panel happening at
comic-con
there's no Marvel Studios comic-con
panel either that's mostly because
they're doing their own special
comic-con event later this year DC is
doing the exact same thing with
something called DC fandom Marvel did
the exact same thing for Marvel phase 3
so it's not the first time that Marvel
has done something like this we already
had the first Morbius trailer they're
probably going to drop the next one around
the time Marvel is getting ready to
start filming spider-man 3 which is
supposed to be around September sometime
and they'll probably just wait to
release the first big venom 2 trailer
either til November or December when the
Black Widow movie comes out they used to
always take footage to Brazil Comic Con
but we don't know if that's going to
happen this year because of the virus
pretty much every convention at least
the ones in real life have been
cancelled they're all going virtual now
so we'll see what the state of the world
is in November but number 4 as far as
big spider-man related cameos go JK
Simmons already revealed the details of
his cameo scene contract for multiple
spider-man Sony movies after spider-man
far from home last year when he showed
up freaked everybody out he said that
he'd actually already filmed his next
big cameo scene he didn't say which
movie it was for but given that he has
multiple more cameo scenes on that
contract as you probably guessed he's
probably going to show up in every single
one of those spider-man related movies
next year the way he talked about the
cameos made it sound like most of them
were small background scenes just like
his spider-man far from home cameo in
the post-credits scene I know everyone's
still scratching their heads trying to
figure out how Sony and Marvel are going to
handle the spider-man crossovers between
the MCU and the Sony spider-verse
like will the J Joe no Jameson in the
Morbius movie be the exact same version
is the one from spider-man far from home
how will they explain that Morbius is
intended to be a direct spin-off of the
venom movies so those movies already
take place on the same world they just
haven't addressed the MCU of it all yet
they already confirmed that Morbius
takes place after the events of
spider-man far from home which is why
the spider-man Easter egg in the trailer
has murderer written on it in graffiti
the curb report
the tobey maguire spider-man costume
Easter egg in the other Toby era Easter
eggs with the Daily Bugle logos and
everything in Morbius is that those
logos are just designed to be a smoke
screen in that first trailer they're
just there to mislead fans and in
post-production they're going to change
those two MCU Easter eggs so when we
actually see the movie next year it'll
be Tom Hollands spider-man costume and
it'll be the Daily Bugle logos from this
version of the Daily Bugle that we saw
in spider-man far from home
number three marble and Kevin Feige
explained that the spider-man sharing
deal allows Sony to reference the events
of any MCU movie the spider-man has been
in so they can include any kind of
Avengers end game Easter eggs they want
in their spider-man movies but that does
not give them access to Robert Downey
jr. Chris Evans or the other big actors
they can only talk about or show what
happened to Tom Hollands spider-man from
his perspective it's a little bit like
the Netflix Marvel shows relationship
with the MCU movies remember how the
Netflix shows would always reference the
Avengers but he never really saw Iron
Man or Captain America walking by the
defenders on the Netflix shows in the
Marvel movie is never really referenced
the Netflix shows except for ant-man
there was a bit of a daredevil Easter
Egg during that I'm looking for this
dude who's new on scene was like
flashing his fresh attack who's got like
bomb moves right oh you got she's like
well we got everything nowadays we've
got a guy who jumps we got a guy who
swings we got a guy who causal so venom
2 and Morbius referencing the events of
spider-man far from home in scenes won't
be that complicated
the movies are designed to be watched by
children so if you could take a child to
the movie end they could understand it
it can't be that complicated the one
thing that the crossover deal does not
include though is venom coming into the
MCU that would actually have to be a
separate deal that they work out Never
Say Never but for now it just sounds
like it's all going to be Sony's deal
figuring out how that works in the MCU
movies won't address that at all so
number two you may have heard the report
last year after d23 that Sony was
looking to sign a new contract with Tom
Holland to cameo and venom 2 in some
small way at the time the big problem
wasn't so much Marvel MCU politics or
anything like that it was really all
just down to scheduling problems because
Tom Holland had to do the uncharted
movie which he's actually been posting
about the last week this is his Nathan
Drake haircut
he's actually posting about having to
work
out with Mark Wahlberg right after they
filmed that movie he was going to roll into
spider-man 3 production this is before
the big virus shutdown the schedule
hasn't really changed they're still
filming those movies back to back but
when this was all happening last year
the thought was is that he wouldn't
actually physically have time to film
any scenes for venom two there's all
kinds of ways around that you can still
have your spider-man cameo scenes
without having to have Tom Holland on
set you could literally just play a news
clip of him from spider-man far from
home on a screen that venom walks by but
it sounds like Sony really does want to
get a full-blown Tom Hollands spider-man
cameo scene in venom two in some way the
jejune to Jameson cameo in Morbius was
really just supposed to be him yelling
and the news about spider-man being on
the run as a fugitive from justice I'm
also assuming that the J jonah Jameson
cameo in venom 2 would be something
similar with just more updates on the
quote-unquote spider-man fugitive
situation he's not really clearing his
name til spider-man 3
so venom 2 is supposed to take place
before that so technically during venom
2 spider-man is still a criminal from
justice just like Captain America was
after Civil War everyone post all your
spider-man 3 title memes but number one
right now there are also reports that
Tom Horn has already signed a new
spider-man contract with Sony for more
movies bigger movies because his last
contract was only for six movies total
those were at Captain America Civil War
spider-man Home Coming Avengers infinity
war Avengers endgame
spider-man far from home in spider-man 3
earlier this year Sony revealed that
they did have plans to make spider-man 4
but they didn't say if they'd signed
everybody to new contracts to actually
make those there's no official release
date for that yet but if they continue
their past release schedule it would
come out 2023 and there was a big
interview video that I posted a while
ago where the Sony boss says that they
do intend to continue sharing spider-man
with Marvel well into Marvel phase 4 and
Marvel phase 5 that a cover Avengers 5
any big Fantastic Four or x-men movie
crossover wherever they want Tom Holland
to show up in the movies the way they
talk about the big venom vs. spider-man
crossover movie it sounds like that
wouldn't happen until after spider-man 3
but there's no release date on that yet
and it would be Sony to announce the
release date so it wouldn't show up on
the Marvel phase 4 or Marvel phase 5
schedule but
let me know in the comments what kind of
spider-man and cameos scene do you want
to see in venom 2 just a post-credits
scene or something bigger there'll be
more spider-man stuff happening later
this year between Morbius venom 2 in
spider-man 3 so of course I'll try to do
videos for everything there's even been
a bunch of spider-verse - teasers
recently - and we have the Miles Morales
spider-man ps5 game that's coming out so
it is a really good time to be a big
spider-man fan when they actually
released that game later this year I'll
probably do giveaways for copies of the
game while you wait for everything
everyone click here to watch Tom Holland
talk all about spider-man 3 and click
here for my venom 2 trailer and easter
eggs video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe I'll see
you guys tonight!